there I am gotta get and who's that Oh
Michels
gotcha Wow I know it doesn't look like
it but that's the first video game I've
ever played
I used to shout at my kids to get off
the PlayStation my 22 year old son has
just emerged from a video gaming stage
but I used to sneer at get a life I'd
say to him as he racked up his kills
look I still have no idea how these
games work but was I wrong all along
just look at 15 year-old Jaden Ashman
the Essex school boy who's been making
headlines after he and his teammate came
second in the fortnight World Cup video
gaming tournament winning a whopping 1.8
million pounds between them the winner
of the same tournament took home 2.4
million pounds
so as the apparently well-adjusted
winners of the fortnight world cup
celebrate their big wins is it time for
us
disapproving Luddites to accept that
gaming is actually a career choice as
valid as any other
[Music]
well if they will have to wear onesies
like that then Rachel no camo onesie
well I tell you what I agree so I
actually agree with you I think I think
actually that we actually back to the
theme I mentioned in my debate but
actually we sneer at younger generations
and the way they do do things
differently but if you look at where a
lot of money's being made these days one
child in America made 22 million dollars
on YouTube you've got youtubers making
money
gamers making money and actually the
truth is it's not really for me about
the money why I think you're right is
beyond the money actually if you look at
a video game I mean they contribute
billions to the economy economically
overall but if you look at video games
they require a serious level of skill to
make the coding involved the design
involved the narrative and storytelling
involved then matching it to the music
it's like you're making an interactive
and you're apparently do your kids on
them for days on end I'm of the
generation when we actually kicked all
this off with Street Fighter 2 sega mega
drives and i used to sit in front I used
to sit in front of the Sega Mega Drive
and play this 19 minutes on yourself or
your kids I know what they need very
differently but no but actually what it
did so I think it's oh my brother is a
computer as a result I have an interest
in IT when Tom's become a software
security engineer I think it can inspire
careers and now if back then you'd said
to ask that the richest companies in the
world would all be tech companies we
never would have believed you cuz we
thought it was a game I mean I I came in
ready to support this but let's not get
too dazzled by the money I think we need
to remember what are they doing for this
I mean let's compare the winner let's
look at the comparison of that prize
money with other sports competitions
they go that the fortnight champion got
2.4 million
Novak Djokovic got two point three five
million for winning Wimbledon I mean you
know these are comparison of the top
championship
fortnight and Wimbledon now do you
really think that Novak Djokovic is
worth less than the 15 year old or 16 or
the whatever he was the one fortnight
Paris you guys are saying you should
value this because look at the money
they're making we just never I think
it's like a valid career choice because
you know you want to earn money
throughout your career and this has
turned out to be a bit of a closed on
the show you want to say something let's
listen to the guy that won the money I'm
still kind of like like wrapping around
my head how much money I've won but it
truly make it easier on like my mom and
all my family like it just be easier and
they're like a lot less stress and
everything me and my mom have had like a
few tension in between like my gaming
and stuff like she's been a bit worried
about them hours I've been planning on
it thinking that like I'm just sitting
in my room wasting my time and
everything but I've kind of like this
has kind of proved to her that I can
actually make a living out of my game in
no one's saying he's worked harder than
a Wimbledon champion is is it a
legitimate career choice Michele yeah
well you can't compare Wimbledon and
gaming and we are in essentially the
fourth Industrial Revolution when it
comes to careers and jobs and
opportunity we keep talking all the time
about job losses relating to brexit but
no one seems to be focusing on job
losses relating to automation and this
new wave of careers and jobs that we
don't even know yet that will exist in
the future so there is a difference
between a casual gamer there is a
difference between someone with almost a
gaming addiction and and what they call
don't laugh it's not my terminology but
on e athletes not my turn we would be
wrong to dis my dismiss and discard
electronics and all of the associated
things that people do as valid career
opportunities whether that's gaming or
doing some well they're rachel they're
enormous industries now so of course
they're also fun and they're also
children are attracted to them so this
is a huge growth economy but I think one
of the problems with this and a few
people have said that the prize money
really was too high and or they should
have put an age limit but one of the
things that comes up with them with that
that it's now given kids the excuse to
say to their parents
you see I should be playing on my game
for eight to ten hours a day and not
everybody will become addicted but
addiction is a problem it is aerobic in
an industry that it's set up very much
like gambling in terms of reward in the
terms of the reward system it uses and
just looking at Jamie calles who is a
gaming addict and what he says in the
school holiday so I would play for
between 12 and 16 hours a day I would
sleep eat and play that was all I sat
through lessons at school in a zombie
State and ended up not even applying to
university because I knew they wouldn't
take me but the psychological effects
were the worst my communication skills
are affected so badly I didn't even know
how to hold a conversation there's also
the stress because when you're addicted
to video games you can get extremely
agitated and angry yes my suspicion is
that that kind of person would probably
be addicted to something or the other
and if it wasn't games it would be
alcohol if it was an alcohol it would be
something else and these are addictive
personalities and addiction is it's
disease is own disease and it finds an
outlet like they do suck you in but
let's here in defense of gaming its her
eat sleep play repeat as it were Matan
of it from Jay Ann Lopez who's the
founder of black girl games it's great
for creating things that think there's
so many is great for distressing that's
why I personally use it to de-stress
from the world so I think that gaming
has these facets of how it can benefit
your health and your well-being but no
one's really exploring it too much
because we're stuck on the kind of
negative side of gaming I'm going to be
honest and which is this as apparently I
genuinely think that I don't want to see
my kids sitting 12 to 14 hours a day and
Jaden good on Jaden for winning all that
money but I'd like him to stop saying
like the truth is the chances of your
kid getting the two points there's not
something that they'll never get with